well let me ask also um
about the immune system you mentioned a
lot of people kind of ask
you know um how can we strengthen the
immune system
to respond to this particular virus but
the viruses in general do you have from
a biological perspective
thoughts on what we can do as humans uh
too if you look at our
traits across different countries people
with less vaccination
have been dying more if you look at
north italy the vaccination rates are
abysmal there and a lot of people have
been dying if you look at greece
very good vaccination rates almost no
one has been dying
so yes there's a policy component
so italy reacted very slowly greece
reacted very fast
so yeah many fewer people died in greece
but there might actually be
a component of genetic immune repertoire
basically how did people die off you
know in the history
of the greek population versus the
italian population there's a
that's interesting to think about uh and
then there's a component
of what vaccinations did you have as a
kid and what are the off-target effects
of those vaccinations
so basically a vaccination can have two
components one is
training your your immune system against
that specific insult
the second one is boosting up your
immune system for all kinds of other
things
if you look at allergies northern europe
super clean environments tons of
allergies
southern europe my kids grew up eating
dirt
no allergies so growing up i never
had even heard of what allergies are
like really allergies
and the reason is that i was playing in
the garden i was putting all kinds of
stuff in my mouth from you know all
kinds of dirt and stuff
tons of viruses there tons of bacteria
there you know my immune system was
built up
so the more you protect your immune
system from exposure
the less opportunity it has to learn
about non-self
repertoire in a way that prepares it for
the next insult
so it's a horizontal thing too like the
says throughout your lifetime in the
lifetime of the
of the people that uh your ancestors
yeah that kind of thing yeah
what about the so again it returns
against free will
on the freewill side of things is there
something we could do to strengthen our
immune system
in 2020 is there um
like uh you know exercise diet all that
kind of stuff
so it's kind of funny um there's a
cartoon that basically shows
uh two windows with a teller in each
window
one has a humongous line and the other
one has no one
the one that has no one above says
health no it says
exercise and diet and the other one says
pill
and there's a huge line for pill so
we're looking basically for magic
bullets for sort of
ways that we can you know beat cancer
and beat coronavirus and beat this and
beat that and it turns out that the
window with
like just diet and exercise is the best
way to boost
every aspect of your health if you look
at alzheimer's
exercise and nutrition
i mean you're like really for my brain
neurodegeneration
absolutely if you look at cancer
exercise and nutrition if you look at
coronavirus
exercise and nutrition every single
aspect of human health
gets improved and one of the studies
we're doing now is basically looking at
what
are the effects of diet and exercise
how similar are they to each other we're
basically taking
diet intervention and exercise
intervention in human and in mice
and we're basically doing single cell
profiling of a bunch of different
tissues to basically understand
how are the cells both the stromal cells
and the immune cells of each of these
tissues responding to
the effect of exercise what are the
communication networks between different
cells
where with the muscle that exercises
sends signals through the bloodstream
through the lymphatic system through all
kinds of other systems
that give signals to other cells that i
have exercised and you should change
this particular way which basically
reconfigure those receptor cells
with the effect of exercise how well
understood is
the those reconfigurations very little
we're just starting now basically is
there is the hope there
to understand the effect on
uh so like the effect on the immune
system on the immune system the effect
on brain
the effect on your liver on your
digestive system on your adipocytes
adipose you know the most misunderstood
organ everybody thinks oh
fat terrible no fat is awesome your fat
cells is what's keeping you alive
because if you didn't have your fat
cells all those lipids and all those
calories would be floating around in
your blood and you'd be dead by now
your adipocytes are your best friend
they're basically storing all these
excess calories
so that they don't hurt all of the rest
of the body
and they're also fat burning in many
ways
so you know again when you don't have
the homozygous version that i have
your cells are able to burn calories
much more easily
by sort of flipping a master metabolic
switch
that involves this fto locus that i
mentioned earlier and it's target genes
rx3 and rx5
that basically switch your adipocytes
during their
three first days of differentiation as
they're becoming maturely besides to
basically become either fat burning
or fat storing fat cells and the fat
burning fat cells are your best friends
they're much closer
to muscle than they are to whitehead
both eyes
is there a lot of difference between
people like that you could give
science could eventually give advice
that is
very generalizable or is our
differences in our genetic makeup like
you mentioned is that going to be
basically
something we have to be very specialized
individuals
any advice we give in terms of diet like
we were just talking about believe it or
not the most personalized advice that
you give for nutrition
don't have to do with your genome they
have to do with your
gut microbiome with the bacteria that
live inside you so most of your
digestion is actually happening by
species that are not human inside you
you have more non-human
cells and you have human cells you're
basically a giant bag of
bacteria with a few human cells along
so how and those do not necessarily have
to do with your genetic makeup
they interact with your genetic makeup
they interact with your genome they
interact with your nutrition they
interact with your environment
they're you know basically um
an additional source of variation so
when you're thinking about sort of
personalized nutritional advice
part of that is actually how do you
match your microbiome
and part of that is how do we match your
genetics
but again you know this is a very
diverse set of um
you know contributors and the effect
sizes are not
enormous so i think the science for that
is not fully developed yet
speaking of dyes because i've wrestled
in combat sports with sports my whole
life or
weight matters so you have to cut and
all that stuff
one thing i've learned a lot about my
body and
which seems to be i think true about
other people's bodies is that
you can adjust to a lot of things that's
the miraculous thing about this
biological system
is um like i fast uh often
i used to eat like five six times a day
and thought that was
absolutely necessary how could you not
eat that often
and then when i started fasting your
body adjusts to that
and you learn how to not eat you know
and it's it was
uh if you just give it a chance for a
few weeks actually
over a period of a few weeks your body
can adjust to anything yeah and that's a
miraculous that's such a beautiful thing
so i'm a computer scientist
and i've basically gone through periods
of 24 hours without eating or stopping
and you know then i'm like oh must eat
and i ate a ton i used to order two
pizzas just with my brother and
you know like so i i've gone through
these extremes as well and i've gone the
whole
intermittent fasting thing so i can
sympathize with you both on the seven
meals a day
to the zero meals a day um so i think
when i say everything in moderation i i
actually
think your body responds interestingly
to these different changes in diet i
think part of the reason why we lose
weight
with pretty much every kind of change in
behavior is because our
epigenome and the set of proteins and
enzymes that are expressed
in our microbiome are not well suited to
that nutritional source
and therefore they will not be able to
sort of catch everything that you
give them and then you know a lot of
that will go undigested
and that basically means that your body
can then you know lose weight in the
short term but very
quickly will adjust to that new normal
and then we'll be able to sort of
perhaps gain a lot of weight yeah from
the diet so
anyway i mean there's also studies in um
factories where basically
people you know dim the lights and then
suddenly everybody started working
better it was like wow that's amazing
three weeks later they made the lights a
little brighter everybody started
working better
so any kind of intervention has a
placebo effect of wow now i'm healthier
and i'm going to be running more often
etc so it's very hard to uncouple the
placebo effect of wow i'm doing
something to intervene on my diet
from the wow this is actually the right
thing for me
so you know yeah from the perspective
from nutrition science psychology
both things i'm interested in especially
psychology it seems
that it's extremely difficult to do good
science
because there's so many variables
involved it's so difficult to control
the variables
so difficult to do sufficiently
large-scale experiments
both sort of in terms of number of
subjects and
temporal like how long you do the study
for
that uh it just seems like it's not even
a real science
for now like nutrition science
you